it is a dark dark day I lost 40,000
Instagram followers today even though
whatever it's the first story but I lost
40,000 extreme followers and everyone's
talking about it
I'm grunge I'm girls no job yeah on my
sad little Club with under of almost
5,000 like what did she do she's bad
girl she but it was 205 thank God it
didn't go below 200 thank God but over 3
million 22.9 let's [ __ ] sad so sad
very sad very unfair we'll get into it
but I just thought that was more
important than good morning Millennials
but good morning Millennials it's a
beautiful Wednesday it's no longer
snowing in New York it's like Thursday
I'm wearing fashioned OVA a melissa
gorga will be joining i believe i hardy
be what was that why yeah I'm wearing it
in solidarity yeah I appreciate it
we're one step closer one day closer and
I realized like yesterday that I'm
bridesmaid like is there anything I
should be doing like you need help
should I I don't even know what
bridesmaids do I don't know what
bridesmaids to you and everyone and
they're like so much of wedding stuff is
such [ __ ] like people are like I
don't have a maid of honor no totally
like okay okay say say like you were my
maid around her I was Olivia's Olivia's
Margo's Margo's was yours yo yo we all
figured it out like then what like right
it's just like a gram in the program I'm
not having a program say so from this
what do you do because my theory is if
you don't know these people walking down
the aisle who let you in here
totally so just do let me know if
there's any bridesmaids duties that you
want me to to pinch out I don't think so
you know I think the only do you I'm
gonna ask if my bridesmaids is like just
just like try not to like complain and
stress me out you know I mean that's it
there is a special place in hell for
bridesmaids who like make it about
themselves
no but not even like making it like it's
like even if you're having an issue no
don't forget to you
right of course not or like yeah yeah
that's yeah that's oh that's nice that's
rule number one
yeah it's like it's your birthday like
you can't be mean to you know right I
mean but on another level yeah no you're
good just you know make sure you have
all your dresses steamed impressed well
I don't even have a dress so we'll see
yesterday I put on my dress just
like you know take a picture just to
remind myself what I was wearing and
then I remembered that I hated it so I
met Jackie upper course I met Jackie at
Bergdorf's where they really don't carry
you know anything over a size six and we
did find a size eight dress there was
literally one emerald dress in the whole
store and not only did it not fit not
only was it three grand but it was also
ugly so that was tough and then we left
and we were we were perplexed when that
happens it's terrible
we were perplexed but like where does
one go for a ball gown and then because
it's not Saks Undercover Boss don't go
there it's not blue yells but you go to
Bloomingdale's all the time you know
exactly what they have so you're not
gonna find anything new there so we had
to think outside the box
right and we went to Macy's which is
Grand Central Station it is honestly
first of all in the worst area ever it's
just a bustling metropolis of sadness
second of all it's too big like they
have a McDonald's and a nanny answer and
they also sell Gucci like it's just too
much there to do dallas trattoria like
they're trying to do too much and with
all the escalators it's literally Grand
Central Station like you could literally
get Barry they do yeah you could be a
mess house you and I could be in Macy's
and never like for two days and never
find each other of course not
literally me and Jackie went on this
escalator and we were going down and
we're like where are we and you look
around Jackie's like we're in Dubai yeah
it looked like one of those huge malls
that there were housewives to Beverly
Hills shop at in Dubai like in the
airports that have trains in it right
and then people go ziplining across the
top it was so [ __ ] confusing but when
we finally found the dress floor it was
honestly it was it was good it was full
of options of all types of dresses so
unfortunately you're looking for a
specific color so your lemonade and the
dealer the color of the season is navy
like everything was an ad that I saw
maybe it's just always around there was
slim pickins for emerald but I did get
two dresses that I like kind of and
whichever ones I don't wear I'm just
gonna return but now I have three
mediocre options yes and you know what
that's like the place I was at for
Olivia's wedding and it all worked out
and these things just have a way of
working themselves out I just I can't be
bothered with it right now you know but
what's so crazy about like and you know
I just shows the color and let everyone
get the gallons of their choice but
what's crazy is usually with bridesmaids
like your siblings or your bridesmaids
and then if you let go to like Bella
bridesmaids or something then your
sister
like the people who are the second most
important people in this wedding are
wearing like trash gowns
no I know and all the other guests look
fabulous you know I always thought it
was weird to have my wedding I was just
like when you think of like oh my
sister's wedding let me get a ball gown
like no you're just getting like a
bridesmaid's dress right and bridesmaids
dresses like aren't typically nice no so
I mean I think everyone should do it the
way we do it but beyond but even still
like we're struggling you don't get to
wear the dress of your dreams you end up
wearing just a regular Treasury
bridesmaid's dress cuz they went for a
fancy emerald gown from Saks the
original one that I have and I literally
look like middle aged 90 year old woman
yeah I know that's not C Mon but I just
look so old and the problem was is that
when I tried on the dress I looked in
the mirror for the first time and I was
like it's fine and then Ben took a
picture of me and Ben is so tall that he
takes pictures at an angle that always
make me look so skinny so he saw the
picture I'm like oh I love the dress
then I hadn't tried it on since then and
I put it on yesterday and I couldn't
avoid the ugliness and the maturity of
the dress mid cherami yeah yeah and I'm
a lot of things but mature is not one of
them no and you don't have to be mature
yet no but speaking of being mature we
have a really interesting development in
terms of guests for next week we do
guests on the morning toasts that are at
highlighting our mature next to me grow
that would be next week [ __ ] I'm not
ready like I literally need to go I was
thinking about everything I was gonna
say is because he he his publicist said
that like he was just as eager to come
on the toast as we are to have him it's
Nick vile
and he'll be on the toast next week and
we're working at the details but like
when I think only the email I can't
believe it's next week like I actually
just got the biggest pet oh my stomach I
like I've been thinking about what I got
to say because like why did we hate him
so much I mean trying to think back to
the genesis this is why we didn't like
him well one we just took umbrage with
him glad calling out Andy on men tell
all or the final rose for B and then
already put a bad taste sir yeah but
like we didn't watch Andy season so that
moment went viral and that was the first
I'd heard of Andy seasons so like I'm
like oh this Nick guy he's an [ __ ]
you know when I first heard of Nick it
was on Caitlin season and then I did a
little research and I watched a clip of
him making Andy so uncomfortable I'm
like oh he's not a good guy
oh so I just knew that Nick was like the
guy who likes such shame Danny sort of
on a knee season then then I the first
real season i watch the crystals so then
I watch Caitlin
we're here for Kaitlyn and Shawn and
we're team Shawn and then this guy Nick
comes in and ruin things and it is and
isn't he the villain for mandeecees I
just gonna say he's definitely just
painted as a villain so I'm sure he has
lots of experience meeting people who
don't like immediately love him right um
so then after that he was pushed on us
as the back you know then he went on
paradise where he was actually fine but
then he was by the way I still ship them
him and Jenna have like why can't they
and he totally dumped her to be the
bachelor where he chose the villain of
his season we're not super Molly so
right it just was all these small things
that builds it up to us China in him and
and I'm gonna apologize and I and I
think we gonna be good I'm not gonna
apologize yeah because I want to hear I
want to hear him out I do think that you
really don't know anyone and it's just
so funny how we think we know everything
about Nick file when we'd never met him
I'm sure he's like literally just like a
nice normal guy who's just trying to
make it in the business it's to fellow
children trying to make it in the
business like we understand yeah I I
just wanna I'm just I hope he's not like
harboring resentment and like it's gonna
come be mean to us you know and he might
be but you know what like weak he just
needs his microphone right um just
kidding no I think I want we should
start first with just like an apology
just where we were coming from and how
just in the one sentence that he said
about the morning toast he taught us so
many life lessons right and you know and
how we really just grew up in that in
that way we definitely just took like
the villain role he was given like we
took it a little far and was just like I
don't know I I wanna I want to talk to
him you know yeah and I be nervous I
didn't realize it was next week already
yeah but you know let's hand it over
with so we can start you know a happy
friendship no but you're right like
those five words that he said just
painted such a different picture of him
if you guys don't know he has a new
podcast and Rachel Lindsay was on and
last week like she brought up an
interview that Raven did on the morning
to us like just not even mentioning the
morning toast like to to make it a
conversation just as like a throwaway
detail of the interview and he was like
oh those girls don't like me and he
could have like on his own platform like
he could have just like went in on us
and he didn't I just thought that was
really mature cause like if I finally
got the opportunity on a platform to
speak about someone who's been speaking
ill of me like you know I would by the
way there's just like so many easy mean
things you could say let's just roll off
the tongue yeah especially when it comes
to us like there's just so many easy
things that you can say Jenna and so I
mean if
let's do so major respect and we'll keep
you posted about the interview of a
lifetime it's really gonna be like I
feel like we should do it like Andy
watch happens live style like no other
contents right like no Fast Five like
just Nick me you Nick Pyle and these
throw me you and Nick V hey that's like
the movie me even to pre yeah you me and
Dupree anyways um so I believe that's
all we have to catch up on later in the
show we're gonna be recapping Beverly
Hills and siesta key and we'll also be
talking tonight's finale of Real
Housewives of New Jersey with most
Eduardo which I'm truly just so excited
for I love her
same she just brings good energy she
always looks so pretty and it's so
annoying ready for Marty they'll be
pushing the pool with you and I love him
I just wish thing I was with him but
then it would be like you know the woman
but in the UM in uh what am i trying to
say in the promo like that they keep
shoving margaret so relaxed like publish
my husband in the pool whereas their
idea who the hell pushed my husband
Danielle said no but when also Margaret
says it no Danielle come sir she's like
who push my husband oh wait I'm sorry
you were saying Marty I thought well
Margaret's husband gets pushed in the
pool
no Marty really Yahoo by Margaret and
Joe Benigno okay okay I'm sorry I got
the whole time I thought it was Joe oh
my god I think was Joe pushing the pool
I wouldn't be here for it no oh my god
okay I understand I understand I
misunderstood I am now understanding
okay whatever without further ado here
are the past five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite of your morning toast okay first
story that we alluded to this morning
some of you might have noticed some of
you might have not but an Instagram bug
has caused Katy Perry and Kylie Jenner
to lose millions of followers
temporarily much like other people so
Instagram users had noticed that they
had fewer followers today than they did
yesterday it seems that Instagram has
conducted a cull of some accounts
leading some users are Nord at their
lower new follower accounts some big
names and large companies have been
affected Instagram released a statement
a few minutes ago that said Instagram
has confirmed that this is a bug the
cause of which it is actively invest
dating in a statement the company told
them forbes quote were aware of an issue
causing a change in account following
numbers for some people right now we're
working quickly to fix this so so
everyone thought it was like you know
bot season the crackdown but yet in I
love bot mageddon because like I love
when people who look checking my
favorite Instagram fakeblock like there
are just some people who have like such
shady practices on Instagram and like
everyday are getting 10,000 followers
and you know that they're either like
paying for services it's just so shady
and I actually love when they do the
bottom again in because as someone who
has a lot of followers and I don't I did
not purchase 40,000 followers
I think it's exciting to see you know my
fellow peers get called out on their
[ __ ] so it's really looking forward to
when I thought that was happening this
morning and then to my own surprise I
lost like over 40,000 followers and I'm
like I didn't buy 40,000 followers and
I'm not shady like I'm not no but you
could experience yeah get in without
ever having bought followers yeah
because like cabbages about you give in
any like any accountant was a lot of
followers is always gonna lose what in
'barmageddon because it's just the
nature of the beast but when you lose
like an huge percentage its shady but
40,000 out of 3 million isn't anything
but it's just upsetting cuz it took me
from 3 to 2.9
that's what's so upsetting um so it's
not bottom again and unfortunately but
fortunately for you you'll get your
followers back is what they were saying
interesting for me and I'm not
complaining yesterday I was following
490 people and that she was felling 491
I was trying to get it to 490 but I
couldn't figure out who to unfollow and
then later in the evening I was
following 470 people so thanks it was so
weird I don't know who I lost but I hope
they don't come back meet you what
happened to the snitch what happened to
you she didn't lose any but she fell was
a ton of people and now to us her number
well I checked my following but I didn't
remember how many they were before so
got it well so that part I don't mind I
hope they don't go some of the people in
the live chat are saying they still see
my followers at 3 million ok that makes
me feel better
should I check again yeah when I sought
you point 9 this morning you'd
understand like my heart sunk into my
vagina because getting to 3 was like
such a big moment maybe like some of the
people that I unfollowed through this
bug are you oh should I go see if I
still follow you oh my god totally oh my
god I just figured it was like random
people do I follow girl with no job
following God may be such a bad sister
well it was tragic and then when I saw
this statement from Instagram I felt a
lot better so I'm assuming everything
that's gonna go back to normal once they
figure it out at least this isn't like a
permanent thing
however Instagram did promise us about
mageddon and it hasn't happened yet
I think they did it no no I don't think
that they did it because love bought
McGavin it's the best day yeah and like
everyone loses followers at Guildhall
you know I'll lose holo it's a normal
position people yeah it's probably like
2 or 3 percent of your overall phone
yeah no big coverage but the people who
lose more than that there's a story to
tell there so I look forward to BOTS
mageddon me too I love but my getting
this was thought thought mageddon yeah
no it was a it was a fake out false
alarm everyone go back to normal I'm
gonna go back to 303 million followers
everyone can relax okay
next story any comment on the cover of
People magazine with his bebut with such
dark hair the baby hats and so much meat
andy cohen's baby the Bravo host
describes his experience in the
delivering room introducing Benjamin
Alan Cohen Andy Cohen and his newborn
were photographed exclusively for people
in this week's issue where the new
father opens up to people and
Entertainment Weekly editorial director
just Cagle about becoming a dad in the
powerful moment he met his first he
first met his baby boy who was born
February 4th via surrogate I was in the
delivery room I had been hoping that he
would have a full head of hair and he
really over delivered watch what happens
live host that was the first thing you
see the head of hair coming out and I
was amazed after Cohen cut the umbilical
cord himself doctors clean Benjamin auth
and brought him over to the new dad who
then went skin-to-skin with his newborn
for the first time he was so alert for
the first two hours his eyes were wide
open he didn't cry he was just calm I
kind of have no words for it so [ __ ]
sweet so [ __ ] cute wait I didn't know
that like if you have a surrogate you
get to like watch I think each situation
is different but you guys like me
together you make up you're right but so
like not only do you as a surrogate like
you give your body to the beat you've
literally also let someone see your
vagine yes that's just something you
don't think about when you were having a
surrogate yeah like has any toaster ever
but a surrogate a hundred percent
interesting business I know to bring
this desire to become a dad to like
Cohen worked with an organization that
helps you find the egg donor and the
surrogate and you kind of package the
whole process you know it's probably
like a choose-your-own-adventure
right it's like wanna see the typos like
one Instagram story one vagina right or
no vagina wait outside the little bit
right I don't quote I worked with an
incredible surrogate she was in
California surrogacy is illegal in so
many states including New York what I
didn't know that I don't understand why
it's a voluntary process obviously my
surrogate just muted as she was giving
me the ultimate gift she gave me life so
I'll be forever indebted to her I wonder
if she's a Bravo fan and oh my god she
totally is that's the thing it's like
with celebrity surrogates like do you
think like Kim Kardashian's surrogate
like where's k'kaw beauty you know now
she definitely doesn't target on the PRS
yeah but most celebrity surrogates it's
like okay even if you know some random
actress has a surrogate it's like okay
you're a fan of her shirt like Andy has
like a cult following and some wescam so
it's like imagine it would be like a
toaster surrogate right like I don't
know it's like you know Reese
Witherspoon had a surrogate it's not
like I love you and right oh my god well
this video just started playing gave me
a fright you know I mean honestly I
don't think I can ever be a surrogate
but like I would do it for Andy of
course
what does skin-to-skin I guess like the
moments right when the baby's born is
super important
yeah and then he was probably laying and
then he like cradled the baby on his
chest
without a shirt yeah yeah without a
shirt yeah I feel like this first couple
moments like when you're born can like
if if done wrong like you become a
serial killer do you know what I mean
it's crazy there's just like so many
things you can do to your baby like good
and bad to like further it's whatever
like they say if you breastfeed it's
like better for brain development like I
don't know like if you play certain type
of music like well the baby become a
sociopath
you know perhaps or like if you give you
a child the master bedroom he'll become
andrew cunanan
excuse me in Gianni Versace the serial
killer who killed him his parents at the
way he was raised was really [ __ ]
weird and interesting and contributed to
it why he was the way he was um but
basically like she was born to an
immigrant family and they moved to like
a middle-class neighborhood he went to
like a really fancy school in like
Beverly Hills or whatever and his dad
was like so convinced he was so special
because he had a really high IQ they
gave him the master bedroom in their
house and their house they had four kids
and their two parents and this [ __ ]
got the master bedroom yeah that every
morning he would wake up and remember
how special he is and that's why they
killed John and right because he just
thought he was special and without
having to do anything
and then he wanted to take everything
from everyone else Wow yeah no it's
crazy I like little things you do to
your babies like either make them
amazing people or like actual serial
killers it's just something interesting
just interesting factoids that are well
interesting speaking of interesting
factoids did you see what I posted on
the morning shows Instagram this morning
what was it you always find your way
back home yes which is the song we were
singing yesterday from the Hannah
Montana movie it was actually written by
Taylor Swift obviously obviously it was
reminding me of the song when I was my
saw that it was like I'm only me when
I'm with you yeah it's very similar to
that aside yeah so good for her just
another banger under her belt next story
speaking of interesting people
Elon Musk lists Belle Belle air smart
home for 4.5 million dollars oh my god
they need to be another movie smart
house that said I was thinking now when
you watch smart house it's like so out
to date I'm like that it's like the
kitchen has like uh nurses it's like so
Theo the refrigerator talks you can get
that at Kohl's yeah no it's just so not
even impressive anymore and like Pat
sucks like Siri Pat out Siri and Alexa
in whatever so because Siri [ __ ] me up
yesterday I was getting my eyelashes
tinted oh yeah and yeah I was listening
to music on my ear pods while I was cuz
you have to like sit there for 20
minutes while the dice it since I was
listening to music you have time your
eyes closed right you have to keep your
eyes closed and a song came on that
agent one here so I you know motioned
around to try and find next on my home
screen I was pressing pause and then I
pressed pause again and so I started
tapping my things like to see and I tap
one of them and Siri goes off and so I'm
quite I don't want her to do anything
calling so this person who I have not
spoken to in five years that's a minute
I still can't open my eyes so I'm like
hoping that it ends or is this person
just see on the other room it didn't
ring and then when I finally got to take
it off it said to call cancelled so it
might have not even made it to me if you
press the side button on the side it
hangs up - oh I didn't know that he had
the power the like luck bus so it's like
why is Siri calling this person when I
didn't tell her to do anything she's out
of control Alexa would never do that
never
well Ellen must she'd definitely film
some sort of Disney Channel home movie
in his home before he sells it agreed
called it smarter house with at least
four other
residences in the Bel Air California
area billionaire Elon Musk likely won't
miss the sleek mid-century modern he
recently put on the market for 4.5
million
he paid 3.6 million for the home in 2014
isn't he a billionaire and like yeah it
seems kind of low but he's also just one
guy you know yeah and put it partly I
feel like like even billionaires like
that build with be billionaires who have
likewise it's like the wives are the
ones who want like that thank you he
also has like a ton of kids oh right um
I was forget that Elon Musk is a daddy
yeah imagine if he was your dad like hey
Dad can we go to Mars today hey dad
could borrow a billion dollars hey Shaan
for what lunch
can my friends and I take a spaceship
hey Dad Billy always wants me
hey dad why'd you call that guy bad fire
hey Dad what happened with you and Amber
Heard hey Dad can we go see the Aquaman
movie even though Amber's in it hey Dad
why does your girlfriend look like a
serial killer hey Dad
what was this alien pink thing about you
yeah hey Dad I thought it was really a
big sub Twitter she was seeing some
crazy stuff hey Dad you keep drugs like
azalea big maybe that's why he doesn't
see his children like too many tough
questions I don't even know if he
doesn't see spaceships I guess that he
like how to wife and kids like with like
six kids yeah cries Li wen hey Dad
when's the Hyperloop gonna be done no
people don't need to get places hey Dad
when you come over for dinner
see well not anytime soon because he's
selling the house ooh but like I love
when I sell ready houses go on the
market cuz you can see their pictures
here at listing crazy also I wanna talk
about celebrity homes let me talk about
my really Hills cuz like how come it's
just like a regular day in the life to
get robbed there we have to talk about
it okay
next story was something that I found
buried that I wouldn't have seen but you
know it's about babka Bob Costas and the
NBC breakup when he stepped when he
resigned it was like a little too quiet
you know
then it was Lee said there's something
more you yes you said it had a smell to
it yeah so this is what they're teasing
and also burying you know on the side
panel of CNN CNN business Bob Costas and
NBC broke up over concussion remarks Bob
Costas told ESPN an exclusive interview
published on Sunday that the
reason he was cut from hosting the Super
Bowl was because of public remarks he
made about the detrimental effects of
concussions on football players Costas
was set to host his final NFL game last
year on Super Bowl Sunday but months
before the Eagles took on the Patriots
on February 4th the famous sportscaster
was dropped from the broadcast setting
the stage for the end of his 40 year
career at NBC Costas who has hosted
nearly every sports event imaginable
from the Olympics to the Kentucky Derby
had been critical in the past of the
NFL's role in the concussion crisis but
remarks he made the year prior at a
journalism symposium when a touch too
far for his bosses I think the words
were you cross the line and my thought
was what line had my crust in 2017
Kostas told the crowd at the University
of Maryland that the reality is that
this game destroys people's brains not
everyone's but a substantial number it's
not a small number it's a considerable
number it destroys their brains ok shut
day that's not what I was expecting but
that's so weird and I thought there was
more going on then it makes it seem like
why would MBC care if you said that it's
like that it fell what cared he said
that maybe it came from the NFL it came
from the NFL the NFL you know probably
broadcast a lot on them you see and
that's big money yeah Bob Costas is out
here like the NFL like is so stupid
sometimes like the concussions CT thing
is very real like why don't they just
get ahead of it instead of like denying
that it exists right and I just have
like one small thing to say because I've
watched a few games in my day and the
concussion thing is very real there's
these tackles people got hurt but they
can stop fellow play when you score a
touchdown then you get your helmet slam
from every which way
and like and it's supposed to be
congratulations and it's also hurting
your head they shouldn't be able to
helmet slam people like intentionally
but unnecessary roughness unnecessarily
helmet slams like so you can still get
some tackles in but you're causing so
much extra damage when like someone just
when you're trying it congratulatory
yeah like just let their ass like a
normal person right so that's just my
two cents
everybody and I'm like oh yeah and it's
like I wouldn't want to score a
touchdown cuz then you're gonna get your
helmet slam totally oh my got a great
call and it's like the NFL has such
shook rules I'm the dances they can do
in the touchdown but now we can give
each other concussions no I don't think
so it's just so weird cuz you feel like
the NFL is like really in tune with like
everything actually not at all but like
I don't know it's just like they're in
denial about this concussion thing and
like any time someone talks about it
they like get all shady and weird like
just be open about it and like give
everyone else in sure
yeah it's real yet like a pension for
health insurance like a government
worker how you have like government
benefits forever yeah you should have
NFL benefits forever that like gives you
access to great doctor care for this
concussions maybe I should work for the
NFL okay they didn't find a story I'm
finding quite interesting um just as you
know like a fellow sling like someone
who adopts language from television
shows American parents say their
children are speaking in a British
accent
after watching too much Peppa Pig what's
Peppa Pig American parents say their
children are picking up British accents
after watching the popular children's TV
show Peppa Pig the cartoon follows the
life of peppa and her family in a UK
fictional town made up of various animal
families toddlers across the world are
now tuning in to see Peppa's latest
adventures and it appears Peppa's
southern British accent and vocabulary
are rubbing off on those watching the
show that is hysterical and honestly
amazing like we're also culture now
parents have shared their concerns on
social media with many blaming the TV
show for causing a change in the way
their children talk a mother in Kansas
City shared a video on social media of
the her three-year-old son Oliver who
started to speak in a British accent
pretty quickly Mollie Smalley said her
son started doing it pretty quickly out
of nowhere when he started watching
Peppa Pig she added would think it's
really funny and he will still do it
Jamie this is what I was saying the
things you do to your kids when they're
young like their brains are sponges like
you can make them into a Sarah killer or
you can make them into a British person
or Adele youtuber Casey neistat's winner
my three-year-old daughter nice stuff
nice NAT wrote on Twitter so like he's a
person my three-year-old daughter speaks
with a slight but pronounced British
accent she learned it from Peppa Pig
that's crazy it's just like how times
have changed like when we were kids like
our Idol was this fat dinosaur like with
no manners now kids are turning into
proper British lads no like when we were
kids we also used to watch Hannah
Montana and then you know all of a
sudden we're like you don't get hot in
here it's hotter than a church on Sunday
and Christmas don't let door hit you
where the good Lord split you and now
children are talking they could have a
fake
I hope she's still around when we have
children because I love this me too I
have all these little dirty Kenzie's
walking around you know it's like kids
are so cute what can my computer
I said yeah except like British kids
have bad teeth so we get like the good
American teeth but like the cool British
accent yes this is just bringing us one
step closer to unity you know that is so
oh my god this is the ghost of King
George coming back I think it's the
ghost of CHS just King George the one
with the American Revolution Oh era all
King George oh yeah no I'm not talkin
bout the kid a little kid I'm talking
about like this is his revenge like we
seceded from Britain now we're all
becoming British it's the ghost of city
just passed it's coming back I want to
talk about Beverly Hills it's like
literally all I came here to do today
the beginning was so shook worthy I love
an edited moment it gave me major Taylor
and Russell Armstrong vibes when he
committed suicide in the season and they
started the season with like now them
all at someone's house like talking
about it and then did like six months
ago
but it made me think two months they
filmed for more than that so that fight
with Lisa must happen in the middle yeah
interesting mm-hmm Ken Vanderpump is the
scariest [ __ ] alive when he gets mad
like when he took called Yolanda stupid
and when he told Kyle to get out of his
house like he shakes me like I would
never want to be in a fight with him
he's so scary and he's always getting
involved where he doesn't like where he
doesn't belong and the thing with
Beverly Hills is like the husband's very
rarely get involved and when they do all
the ladies agree it's like no more
husbands like my PK and Bob they're like
give him a diamond like they're like
enough you know yeah but Ken their home
it's like he's like the exception he's a
[ __ ] sniper from the side you're good
he's the exception feet for each other
like in in Jersey they welcome the
husband's like they wanted in Beverly
Hills there's like a strict no husband
thing but Ken Bennett from Todd every
now and then just gets in and he he
takes it to a level that's like
unacceptable like yelling and women's
faces like you're not allowed yeah
really Ken in this climate okay first of
all I've never been so excited for a
premiere of anything I know I was
literally doing a countdown watching it
live making popcorn like watching yes so
exciting I watched you live which was
like I haven't done that I'm a siesta
key because of it and I can record
Beverly Hills but I can't record siesta
key and I just I missed it anyways it
was so good
so a couple of the opening scenes that
just really showed us where we're at
today like Lisa Rinna doing go yoga with
their kids was hilarious
I like me a little sad for the goats but
it was fun right they got to tackle
Delilah Belle do that a yoga studio in
like Malibu is no place for a goat yeah
it should have been out an outdoor yeah
yoga situation but it was funny as
someone who did karaoke and wanted to
kill herself
yeah um to read and Erica Jane coming to
her house having oh my god and Erica
Jane is so cute what's so interesting is
like she's this modern woman like living
her dream and she lives in a house that
is like from the 17 oh it's the oldest
like it's a manner like and every time
she puts out food it's all pre-prepared
with saran wrap on it right so funny I
had like a lemon cake like the cake that
in confessions of a shopaholic sexy
bloom woods mom brings out and you know
a let it takes a little sleeper yeah no
plates are like you know all this like
Bill Murray and Bach from like the 90s
yeah so like a vintage it's so not what
you expendable she's so it's so much mr.
Rd it's so the house of who you think
would be married to Tom Girardi right it
has a chapel in it so I'm never I'm
never not shocked by it's just seeing
bits and pieces of her home no I know it
was so it's so funny and when she
entertains it just feels wrong
so if you know I mean so wrong like her
with this cookies with saran wrap no it
was Erika Jayne oh and saran wrap I was
making no sense and they weren't even in
the kitchen like it was so weird Erika
Jayne has leftovers so the majority came
over and said she also got robbed I was
thinking like and and then Erika was
like it happened to us once like you
just come she said actually no I have hi
every five years
Oh five times five times it's just like
uh is that like a relatable thing like
except that and then I was and then I
says act how come everyone like in
California just gets robbed and he was
like as everyone knows where the
celebrities live I was like okay that's
there but if Erika Jayne has been robbed
five times that would mean before she
was ever a celebrity just like ran the
husband is very well known that's what
it is
but he's just like oh like they're just
robbing everyone yeah I mean definitely
being on a reality show and showing
their house makes you a much easier
target and then also showing all the
trips you taking all the bags you have
and when you're not there you see on
social media robbers dream and Tom
Girardi is definitely a well-known
person enough before that before the
housewives that him being robbed it
makes sense but it's so horrible like I
like someone being in my space oh my god
like I wanted like even when I invite
people and they're in my space I feel
wrong you know yeah and like all of a
sudden you come
you just like have no bags and no
jewelry horrible Kyle's house looked so
good I love her furniture like and I
usually don't like Faye Resnick's design
style like every time she's doing like a
meeting with Faye and face like mocking
stuff I'm like and that is ugly and
tacky but I think the house looks really
good
I think the house exhale good but like I
just it gives me a pit still and I know
she's restocking her Birkin collection
in this week's episode we saw a pink
army yes in which I just which she
obviously just got since she got robbed
and she had a Kelly Birkin when she's
fighting with Lisa in the box oh yeah
yeah so in two months she raised to do
two Hermes bags and I'm glad for her so
ever if they got like a good insurance
yes
payout the crew of Lisa Rinna Denise
Erica and Joey is like my crew this
season and I hope they stay together the
Serena Eric Henry and Denise too cuz
Sunnis his friends with her I got that
flashback of Charlie Sheen licking
Elise's toes like I wanted to die I was
crying but I'm still on the fence about
Denise Richards I'm not just gonna like
her because she's famous and that's not
something and I like in the house why no
I don't like her because she's famous I
like her because she starts with Lisa
Rinna right but Hollywood Moms Club she
needs to earn her spot yeah yeah the
Hollywood moms fun and it's like all
people talk about is Charlie Sheen with
her right now so and they were only
married for four years no I know but
like there was so much of the press
about them and like the four years that
they were married but like the four
years or like he was like that you want
to have men with a whole thing yeah yeah
Tiger mud so I'm really looking forward
to seeing what she brings to the table
and they love like I love Erika Jayne
because she's clearly she's a really big
fan of just like movies and TV I think
she grew up like I was like yeah in
front of the TV set and just loving it
and like the way that she just like
approaches being a fan with Denise it's
like she's still so cool even when she's
being a fan like I love doing this I
love doing that tell me about it no one
thought you could be an astronaut that's
like what a normal person would do
around a celebrity she's so relatable
she's so related we need to talk about
that scene of Vanderpump dogs that guy
who works what did was in Brian who like
knows teddy from the cycle I mean
whatever he is such a little like ship
starter he's loving being on TV but it's
so obvious that Lisa told him to bring
it up like please Lisa did not let she
was being a good actress at first I was
like oh she doesn't want it spoken about
and then when he blatantly disobeyed her
and she said no don't talk about and
then they sat down and were trying to
change the subject and he brought it up
again it's obvious that least I told him
do you think so
you think that I just thought maybe she
felt like not right here right now like
obviously I'm just gonna come up but I
don't I think she wanted to talk about
other things that day I was giving her
the benefit of it they didn't harp on an
important detail in that situation which
was they said okay so they got the job
the bite on
PK's nose that was crazy and that was
after a lot of bite times children right
so the been wanting to get rid of the
dog is totally fine
yeah very reasonable when you have
little kids and you've an aggressive dog
it's just not a it's not okay but they
didn't give us enough detail about who
they know it went to they didn't even
say til like like three conversations
later that they found a woman who came
to the house like it was just confusing
I would she would have given more detail
about that like who's that woman right
and I didn't realize that there was a
woman I thought they gave it to the
shelter like it was just confusing yet
cuz the way that it is in the press it's
that dream you know she doesn't she's
knocked her off at the shelter and
that's [ __ ] up because if you're gonna
drop it off drop it off at their pump
dog yeah um but maybe she felt that she
couldn't maybe remember when she said I
signed something but I didn't read it
maybe it was that you can't return the
dog to Vanderburgh dogs right and it is
a totally acceptable things you find a
good home for a dog that you can't you
can no longer have and give it to that
family that's fine she did the right
thing i she thinks and she tried we need
to hear from this woman I mean yeah
where is she
but like I felt I don't fault to read
whatsoever like it's just like in panic
mode hit my family's being bit where can
I go pump it's like being kind of
reasonable but she's just being shady
about it like why does she keep bringing
it up you know and it's like Kyle's
right and she said like in Beverly Hills
you got the reputation no but it's like
now they're famous so you've got a
reputation for like like Lena like Lena
Dunham got a jog and like did something
with it and it's like if you get
reputation for her Jewish boyfriend that
end but something else where like she
had got a rescue and gave it or whatever
that kind of reputation it's like a like
like that you're like cruel to animals
like that's terrible yeah but I'm not
that's not I'm I don't believe that like
I live I don't believe that doreet is
that way like and you know what about
yes and you know everyone can decide for
themselves she Dolly's animal lives over
human lives she prefers you know she's
not crazy about [ __ ] but she loves
yeah um but like Doreen is placing her
children above this dog
of course as well she should but it's
lisa is being reasonable in her side
commentary she's saying I don't fall she
said it's a terrible situation like that
it was just really like miss like
unfortunate but I don't blame to read at
all but then she's just being shady with
like Teddy and but bringing it up and
it's just weird so it's definitely I
think it's like it's crazy that so much
happened before the season is usually
this would happen you know you would see
her getting the dog during the season he
has like so much happened we're not
catching up yes I think literally the
entire like downfall of the season has
to do with this situation yeah and I
think Teddy's a knowing that someone is
put because remember we reported this
story on the show someone was pushing
these stories that this is like someone
in this grew in the camp he really wants
it out there that jury returns returned
the dog and her in Mandan from our
friend and you know when it kind of
makes sense that if Lisa is the one
doing it because I think she would
rather have this story be like to Rita's
mean to dogs and returns the dogs other
than Vanderpump dogs is selling
aggressive dogs not selling like
fostering right other or that you know
Vanderpump is jealous of Kyle and
Ernie's friendship right now there's
just so many layers to unpack I'm really
excited that barbecue looked so fun I
loved Teddy's new house me too it is so
nice and I just loved all the closets
and you can see that she's a real mom
like her closets were a little messy he
has the Restoration Hardware cloud couch
like she is dedicated to being
comfortable in her own home I actually
when I was at one on my Restoration
Hardware rant Teddy Mellencamp did
respond she's like my husband bought two
and I'm furious at him because they're
white and we have kids right before we
need to bring Melissa out but I have one
more thing to say okay we could also
come back after most yeah no no it's not
um this is my last thought I saw
something on Twitter that was really
interesting and it was like a lot of the
LVP stands are like you're being so mean
she just lost her brother blah blah and
totally true but remember how mean Lisa
Vanderpump was to Eileen Davidson the
season that she lost her mom and never
spoke about it just I just wanted to
feel for that okay to bring a Melissa
Gorga we will be right back
you
just three girls on display hello
everyone welcome back we have melissa
gorga again the lesson you actually
haven't been to our new sec as we did
just podcast last time i'm sorry so pink
and pretty i should've wore a pink dress
oh well sorry i feel so feminine in here
I am so excited to talk to you the last
time we spoke to you you said it was
right before it was like season 3 I mean
episode 3 of the season you said Andy
Cohen texted me and said wow this is the
best season of Jersey maybe in a long
time I'm like a really long time and you
were totally right thank you so much and
I died I really think it was like it was
good there's one person responsible Joe
Gorga I am loved VIN Joe we're just like
getting involved only when it's
necessary you know like holding back
fights at Milania song party like I just
love him so like you might have some
competition I'm not gonna lie now that I
must snatch like maybe me and Joe Gorga
out like have a future together I don't
know um he likes a nice Jewish girl tell
me a little bit about like him on the
show like does he love it does gu
dictate like joe back off like yes so I
mean I've tried I can't really the more
I try to dictate or kick him under the
table the more he acts out so I've
learned to just let him go with it and
then not take responsibility and you'll
hear I used to put us as two people as
one what do you wanna call that we used
to like peas in a pod yeah now I'm like
no he's Joe and I'm Melissa so whatever
he says is what he says and whatever I
say is what I say but there's like a
second show happening with the husbands
and obviously that comes to a head
tonight yeah a lot of people I don't yes
like so Joey to spin-off show Joe and
Joe I know everyone keeps saying me and
Joanie did flip houses together yes
doing this like he's doing real estate
seminars and all this stuff now that
he's coming out with so it's pretty
crazy but yeah there's there's men
flying tonight a lot of man drama they
can't wait I mean I didn't think you
could get any better than that episode
in Mexico I mean that dinner did you see
me no I that was so funny the wrong girl
with the glass she was being so nuts I
mean Jennifer and Jackie were here last
week and I just have to say I love
Jennifer and definitely she loves her
energy yes she's so funny and I think
she definitely like regretted that
moment and you know when you're drunk
you do crazy things
um do you guys hang out off-camera
because she said she doesn't really
drink she started drinking like with the
lady
and I think she's coming out of some
type of she'll listen she has a lot of
kids he's five children she I don't know
if she admitted to having an arranged
marriage but she definitely was set up
on a date with him of some sort so I
feel like this is like her time to shine
yeah and and I'm I'm here for it like me
- I appreciate that like I feel like she
and I get that because I went through
that when I first got on the show it was
like right mommy Judy wifey Duty life's
all about Joe because he has to build
his buildings and I'm gonna cook his
dinner when he gets home and I'm gonna
make sure my kids look perfect in their
nails are cut and like the bows on her
head so perfectly when she gets there
yeah and now I'm like [ __ ] you ha ha ha
like I got [ __ ] to do yeah and I think
Jennifer is also like let me free give
me a drink I think actually I've seen
her out down the shore hmm after we
filmed over the summer and she was like
where are we gonna go tonight are we
gonna go out I mean what kind of
nightclubs are down here I was like whoa
girl I get that back - I feel like that
happens with a lot of the franchises
it's like you're opened up to like this
whole new world of just like that's
right everyone gets a divorce I'm sorry
these women trim me let me get their
wings and they're like ready to fly and
sometimes I just can't handle it yeah
and it's not that you don't love your
husband I think you get jaded it's very
easy to get a divorce when you become a
real housewife because yeah these girls
come from true housewife status into
like well I'm a strong business right
and and if you can't handle that you
know these girls get divorced that's
really that's a great point um I want to
talk about you and Teresa because there
seems to be a divide in the group right
now it's like the Jennifer Jackie Oh
Jennifer Danielle Teresa yeah Margaret
you Jackie
right um how does that how is that you
and Teresa have like a volatile
relationship and now you're on two
separate sides does that affect it
whatsoever
um yeah definitely when you guys see the
reunion you're gonna be in shock so it's
him already it's filmed already I mean
it's literally shocking and I'm this is
not me like promoting the show like for
real like my mouth was dropped off the
whole time Teresa and I go at it really
not very unexpectedly for me right I
feel she had an agenda didn't give me a
little heads-up on this agenda didn't
let me know how she was feeling right
about things and like went for my
jugular like within three seconds Wow it
was something I hate when you guys fight
I know I
clearly see and this is like I'm not I'm
like I might I was like I was just at
your house we were just eating right
right out of nowhere I was like is this
like what am I missing
that's crazy Andy Cohen look to music
what's happening I'm like oh my god yeah
Wow our tree sending out still close
yeah besties up each other's paths that
is so there's so many weird dynamics and
it's frustrating for me as a viewer I
think there is so much potential in a
best friendship between you Margaret and
Jennifer and I know that Jackie really
is I mean we were they were here
together and I just don't think they're
they're right for each other they are so
Jackie and Jennifer couldn't be more
opticool it's like polar freakin hot so
I think the possibility of my trifecta
it's really difficult because Jackie and
you and Margaret are close but Jennifer
will never it won't work you know
Jennifer has more of that quirky like
she's more like Teresa like she's yeah
like that I can't explain it she just
goes well with Teresa and Jackie goes
well with me and Jennifer it's just we
just think more alike yeah it's you know
it's just different types of people it's
upsetting for me because I really feel
like there's a lot of potential never no
alliances always change right if you
never thought would be friend they do to
me and Teresa like Danielle and Teresa
for instance well Teresa is a very like
you know Danielle is very like yes
Teresa sure see these Sager is the
Esther is Tracy you're the best you're
the prettiest you're the sexiest you're
the gorgeous this you're the thing
they're besties now yeah well maybe
we'll hold that hope it's actually
really rare that you have two new
housewives who both really made an equal
splash I think Jennifer was like a
little bit more out there but they both
contributed a lot to what happened this
season and I'm happy so that way I'm
very like Jennifer had a great season
yeah and if Jackie was important she was
she was in important and Jackie had
balls this season right which is your
husband listen what I say and she
reminds me of me in in similar ways
because when you don't naturally have
that kooky craziness which I feel that
Jennifer kind of does she does have that
little like you know she's got that
little vibe to her Jackie is more of
like a level-headed like and you're
still able to come out and like tell
your truth and say you don't agree with
something and take the pressure I don't
know I like Jackie a lot this is a
question from Instagram
what was going through your mind when
the words monkeys [ __ ] ha ha ha came
out of Margaret's mouth and then
Jennifer's mouth and did you understand
the reference was like a monkey probably
it was just so shocked see did you guys
see what I do have all season long hide
myself come back any napkin I could find
on any dinner table is like in front of
my face the whole time see that was just
behind hi I have given the facial
expressions of the viewer did you that's
like my new job
ya know literally in shock we haven't
had a moment like that we're like we
probably say a monkey's ass hole that
used to [ __ ] said once a week once a
week on the show I hear it all the time
it's on par with like the table flip
like that's how iconic it's so funny
it's pretty amazing to the point but you
don't realize we were in a really nice
restaurant in Cabo it's really nice
people around me but we're having like
date night the two were cheering with
their wines this was happening and
they're like I'm monkeys [ __ ] it I was
like oh people were like frozen staring
at us I was like this is why we have it
this is why we're gonna be known as
crazy people right like well that's
amazing
that's what's so funny is like when when
you when you guys go on trips you wore
off and then I have a private room for
dinner right now they like always are
you in the events like once in a while
they'll give us a private room because
they know shits gonna go down right so
like that last night that was a very
private sector had it set up nicely so
wild with the blast braking wile a
switch there was a switch that what
happened in her but then you when she
broke the glass against you listen I
listen I'm I'm nice I'm very cool I'm
fun yeah I'm a fun drunk I'm the one you
want to hang out with if you're like
going out and want to have a good time
but like if you're gonna stare at me in
my eyes for real it was like a threat
yeah it was like a break right I'm like
what was I gonna do Stan there's like
okay things like my instincts were like
I will kill you yeah this is a good
question from Casey Ashley has Joe's
outlook on you owning and be changed at
all since what he said on the show and
then seeing himself on the show say it
um I think it's helping because he sees
the fans reaction of what he's saying
and I feel like he always thought he was
right right right right right and when
he has so many people telling him like
you're an [ __ ] you're wrong he's like
alright well you know I don't like I
told you yeah you were an [ __ ] it's
very slight we're to like see yourself
on TV and it is even for me like certain
things I done
I was a little [ __ ] at that look like
you know so I think it's helping me to
have him on national TV and saying these
things out loud because he's like the
majority the people do not agree and we
love him so it's like yeah absolutely
thing about Joe it is he's never gonna
be one of those guys that everyone hates
cuz he doesn't have a bad heart he wears
it's hard to sleep he's a lover do you
know what I mean Joe's a trailer I love
so it's like he has this mentality but
it also is what makes him such an
amazing husband right want to tell me
I'm beautiful every day and want it like
you know what it means it's like it's so
hard to hate Joe right the last we spoke
oh sorry oh the last we spoke you were
talking about moving to California where
do we stand now a few months later um my
house is still for sale so we'll see
what happens with that I mean it's it's
it's a thought but it's not like a
definite thing everyone went crazy for a
little while everywhere I went that I
was moving to California and it's not in
stone I'm gonna look I'm definitely
gonna go look once my house sells but
it's not like in stone at all right okay
um have you pursued looking for your
sister and have you had any me well
you're gonna see that tonight oh yeah
yes oh so that's gonna be that's a crazy
conclusion will be tonight did you do
23andme yes you did yes that can be
helpful curious well when when you said
that the psychic said that you had
another sister I think we were gonna say
it's Theresa it turned into a whole
different show like am i watching zo
strangers ah it took maybe she met that
my father burns yet another child that's
so crazy
yeah so did you fire are you okay which
we can tonight on Bravo at 9:00 p.m.
Eastern Time I don't know what time that
is everywhere else but figure it out
Thank You Melissa for being everyone
follow Melissa on instagram once
Instagram gets its [ __ ] back together I
know it's like circling today it's so
annoying and that's all we got we're
back tomorrow with just some more
deliciousness we will see you then bye
you